20-17 celebrated adaptation of Stephen
King's it is now out on DVD and blu-ray
and there are plenty of deleted and
extended scenes to savor in all there
are eleven added segments included in
the film's bonus features so let's run
through what's new and how the new clips
fit into the overall story and of course
here's the all-important spoiler alert
for anyone still waiting to get spooked
by penny wise fake out the first scene
included in the bonus features as an
alternate take of the iconic opening
moment when little Georgie dem bro
chases his prides paper boat down the
rain stream and that gets sucked into
the sewer drain where penny wise the
dancing clown is hiding but instead of
having his arm ripped off and being
dragged into dairies dark water in this
version he simply grabs a boat and
wanders off saying penny wisest reaction
to Georgie's unexpected escape first
it's all in confusion then he finally
Etta's dad guilt next up we have the
seam of Stanley's father chiding him
over his lack of preparation for his Bar
Mitzvah
we already saw him correct his poor
pronunciation and remind his son that
he's a rabbi but in the extended version
he goes for broke with the guilt trip
not only does he essentially tell him he
needs to take responsibility for a soul
but he also rattles off a list of
exactly who he stands to let down if he
messes us up with that kind of pressure
looming on the home front
it's no wonder Stanley's the most
burdened of the bunch family friction
one thing that seemed to be a little
lacking in the theatrical version of it
was the emotional toll that Georgie's
disappearance would take on the rest of
the dem bros in a new scene though we
find out that not only are they
completely broken but it's bill who's
being inconsiderate and aloof about
everything his mom has shown silently
laboring over the dishes as his father
reads a magazine and bill starts
prattling on about planning their annual
summer park trip his mother wants
nothing to do with it and storms off and
that's when it's that informs them that
it's not happening this was Georgie's
favorite trip so it doesn't matter how
much everyone else liked it it's done
second skeptic another scene that's
extended is a woman bill flees from the
basement after seeing a phantom Georgie
and Pennywise down below
well if you look on Wesley - he ones -
his father upstairs and explains what he
saw which prompts his father to explore
the room right away even though bill can
clearly hear his dad sloshing around the
flooded basement his dad still returns
to report that it's dry as bone and that
it must have been a bad dream
like other clueless adults around town
his dad doesn't see or hear what's
really going on and thinks it's just a
product of Bill's cruel imagination
grown-ups unhappy home an aspect of the
original its story does mercifully
glossed over in the cinematic adaptation
as he abused her me bowers suffers at
the hands of his alcoholic father in a
new scene though he's shown struggling
to apply ointment to lashes on his back
implying he's being whipped by his mean
old man and that this isn't the first
time upon Henry's attempt to leave the
house his father demands that he fetch
him another beer first and he complies
without any ounce of hesitation or
attitude but by the time his friends
arrive hem reads back to wearing his
tough-guy air nosey touch smell rip his
head off as they're about to leave -
they spot Mike Hanlon passing by on his
delivery bike which sets up the quick
scene with Mike being bullied by the
trio as Pennywise looks on fighting fear
Stanley's emotional defection from the
rest of the losers is also evident in a
new scene from the niebolt house when
half the losers play lookouts Stan cries
to Mike about how he doesn't want to go
in the house and it's clear he just
can't handle what's happening to all of
them right now meanwhile the scene also
sets up a pretty tender exchange between
bed and Beverly as they wait for the
others he places a hand on her shoulder
and she was sepra Kate by placing her
hand on top of his own an exodus the
next scene is only a slight extension of
the niebolt house scene that scared the
hell out of everyone in the theaters but
in a new piece of the sequence we get to
see how the group reacts to fighting
their way out of Penny wises clutches
the first time with Eddie's broken arm
he has to be carted away on Mike's bike
ditching his own ride in the street and
they're all otherwise in the collective
state of panic as they scramble to flee
the scene
seeing their post-battle fear in action
like this it's pretty clear why there
might be so quick to the span moody
monologue
Stanley URIs might be a shrinking violet
throughout the film but he gets one
scene of serious retribution in his bar
mitzvah monologue
in the extended version of a ceremony he
lays into his father and the whole
synagogue by cordon amount for being out
of touch with the dangers around town
becoming an adult according to the Holy
Scripture Derry is learning that perhaps
not surprisingly the only one who claps
for him is Richie trashmouth tosia
caster van Dahl in another briefly
extended scene we're finally shown what
Eddie's face looks like when he realizes
that Beverly's bully has signed this
cast with the word loser down at the
pharmacy and to make matters worse we
also see her Tucker chewed up what if
gum on top for an extra dose of
germophobia slaughter session the most
shocking added scene of them all
features Henry Bowers now possessed by
penny wise parked outside the niebolt
house with his face covered in blood he
watches us a loser's prepared to go in
and attempt to rescue Beverly from the
clown back leaves to his lab that's when
the camera pans to the passenger side
and we see that both of his side kicks
up at their neck slashed presumably by
Henry's newly reacquired knife it's then
that the losers enter the house not
knowing that they have a twisted Henry
lurking behind them if included the sea
might have taken away the elements of
surprise when Henry shows up and attacks
my but it may have also sets up the
eventual excuse Jerry folks adopt about
all the deaths as they pin them on Henry
the walkie-talkie in the theatrical
version of EDS build embro doesn't get a
real sign of his brothers fate until
after they vanquish Pennywise but in an
extended version of the scene he
stumbles upon Georgie's walkie-talkie
first thing considering the condition of
the device it appears to be unbroken and
perhaps even functional the find might
have given him false hope about his
brother's condition and cause confusion
in the final fight so it's probably for
the best that the filmmakers let him
have his big showdown with the clown
before handing him George's old stuff
family vacation the original film ended
after the losers said goodbye but the
alternative version of the closing
moments would have ended on a slightly
more optimistic note for at least one
character the unused ending included in
the bonus features that shows bill's
parents packing up the station wagon as
his mother comes out to kiss him and say
they'll make new memories with a new
vacation spots
now that they've all come to accept
Georgie's fates they're finally starting
to heal but just to make sure no one
gets too cozy but the camera eventually
pans to the storm drain that was such a
problem for them in the first place just
as it begins to rain there's no
Pennywise in there yet but it's clear
his reign of terror is far from finished
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
Jack holders cool stuff we know you're
loved too
[Music]